hace una semana Seguidores del
presidente
están acampados en el centro de Río de
Janeiro enfrente del cuartel general del
ejército protestan contra la victoria de
Luis Ignacio Nacional
del 30 de octubre y dicen que hubo
fraude a pesar de que no hay pruebas
Brasil
[Música]
l
robaron 6 millones de votos de nuestro
candidato que es Yair bolsonaro Mi voto
no fue computado Pero cuál es la prueba
hay pruebas los militares hicieron una
auditoría y están averiguando si hubo
fraude solo el presidente del tribunal
superior electoral no quiso ver estas
pruebas
si la fuerzas armadas no encuentran
ningún indicio de fraude Creo que vale
la pena también Escuchar La voluntad del
pueblo
al final de cuentas vivimos en una
democracia estamos manifestando nuestro
derecho de hablar de Buscar pruebas lo
que no aceptamos es este sistema de
gobierno entonces solo nos quedan las
fuerzas armadas
no vamos a salir de aquí puede llover
puede pasar lo que sea vamos a
permanecer firmes aquí hasta que nos
esclarezca todo eso
Ese es el campamento donde desde hace
una semana los manifestantes duermen
comen y cenan no hay fecha para irse
dicen que se van a quedar hasta que el
último corrupto de Brasil se ha
expulsado porque su lucha dicen es una
lucha popular contra la corrupción